oui j'arrive à l'eau jean daria quoi
rien non non c'est bon un moment dd
c'est vraiment bon tu m'entends bon
ouais on est à salé ouais t'as cru bon
alors tu dois te bats on habite à dugny
3 unis bah comme ça s'écrit sans van des
128 boulevard de la source lotissement
16 bâtiments à un escalier b jairo ses
portes 1094 ouais ça fait du monde à
droite on rentre on a une fausse alerte
ben alors tu la connais ma maurice et
laurent est mis à l'épreuve de la même
religion que la nôtre alors elle m'a
donné la barre est ma baraque à bab
ouais j'étais bien contente d'aider
aussi mais manque quand même un jeu vous
est ce que ça veut dire parce que des
moindres on sait pas alors louisette à
l'a fait l'espagne est derrière elle
doit connaître
oui merci quoi on est très très bien la
maison
j'ai par le visa qui on se croirait
presque à la cantine j'entends les
visuels
alors ça c'est rien non c'est rien c'est
le passage
ouais j'ai oublié de te dire du balcon
de la cuisine tu vois non et ben moi je
vois les avions atterrir sur la piste
juste à côté de nous ouais mais là ça
change un peu de sa brawn mais on peut
pas passer toute sa vie à sa brawn a
officié pour toby parce que de l'autre
côté j'ai quand même la chance d'avoir
le périphérique juste en dessous alors
tu penses avec les éclairages de la
route
on voit très bien comme ça pas besoin
d'allumer la lumière quelle économie
même le match tu sais que dd se lève
tous les matins à 5 heures 30
pourquoi tro menez are so c'est l'heure
du baba cool hirt le premier vol de
lutter quoi anna cros ah non je connais
pas non c'est ma voisine du 14e qui me
lis quoi les gens sont très gentils avec
très forte parce que j'ai foutu nous
andrier je le vois pas pourquoi qui nous
ferait la gal ba ya quoi bah oui il
était aussi en 13 lucky brand maire de
paris la boa trophy
parfois elle il a les pieds tu ouvres
phl forcément on est chauffé par le sol
hardy dont je vais te faire une surprise
dimanche prochain c'est à l'émission de
radio à 532 le temps va à venise et
bretagne par tino rossi
c'est un rappel rabab des contacts ce
taux rate pas je penserai via la toile
en même temps que le bal un coup dur
c'est la même heure et ben voilà la
petite mort voilà toutes les nouvelles
de temps brasserie ben non c'est pas
l'avion fait dédé qui va me prendre à
l'ouganda mâche pas encore trouvé sa
l'onu bon bah écoute tu embrasses
bien-être la malène bourgeois puis
maladie j'ai oublié de dire j'ai j'ai
acheté trois bouts la teinture aux pour
la route de l'os en coupant les branches
et bah je pense pouvoir la ressortir
pour l'arbre de noël
notre prochaine sortie à la mutualité
mais j'espère qu'elle a bien pris malgré
les tâches sous le bras as tu vois si
bon a lyon je raccroche pas ce que ça va
te coûter de fortune tout ça voilà tout
va bien je t'embrasse tout va bien tout
va bien joli ballet